[Music]
hi everyone this is bruno aziza and
welcome to another edition of data
journeys this is where you come to learn
from leaders in data and analytics
people that have had amazing growth
incredible results who tell us about
their journey also what uh we need to do
and what we need to avoid doing today
i've got the honor to be here with joe
from telus joe thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us today tell
us a little bit about telus perfect
thanks for having me bruno so i work at
telus telus is the third largest
telecommunications company in canada we
represent wireless wireline systems we
also have some interesting divisions in
health agriculture and iot our wireless
division represents nine and a half
million subscribers across canada so
that's a fairly large sample of people
within the country of 36 million and my
group specifically is telus insights uh
our division was founded in 2015 and
we're really focused on trying to
commercialize data in a privacy
preserving manner so that means taking
data that we have as a company and
bringing it out to market in a way that
the privacy of the individuals or the
devices that the data comes from isn't
being impacted negatively by anything we
do and everything's looking at
aggregates we really see this as a
market differentiator compared to other
data monetization groups at other
companies and we've seen this lead to a
lot of the success with our product to
date that's excellent so how to monetize
data in a secure manner you also have
amazing scale tell us a little about the
volume of data that you're dealing with
and the types of inputs that you're
getting yeah so our primary data set we
focus on is our wireless subscriber
location so it's location coming off of
our network we get network events
anytime a cell phone talks a network so
it sends a signal when it makes phone
calls text message as it migrates
between towers or anytime it's been
inactive for about 30 minutes or so and
so with that we're building about 74
billion location records every month and
we have about 275 000 unique points of
interest on the map that we split up
into about five thousand different
unique polygons and that number of
polygons continues to grow month over
month as more users start using our
system and upload their own custom areas
to look at and this result in us
analyzing over 1.2 petabytes of data um
this year
that's quite incredible so the products
involved here bigquery of course data
flow pub sub composer and a whole host
of other products you also analyze data
in in data studio tell us a little bit
about the uh the first use case here
that you you've been primarily involved
in is the data for good uh use case yeah
so when the pandemic hit um in mid-march
in canada we said as an organization
there's something we need to do about
this and we need to provide data out in
a way that
reiterates our stance in the market
towards privacy so really focuses on
what we can can't do with data but also
gives access to that data to government
organizations and researchers who have a
real need and a desire to use data to
inform their decision making and help
them make the right decisions at the
right time so we opened up to this
concept our ceo signed off on it our
chief privacy officer chief data and
trust officer i should say was really
backing this and supporting it and so
we've managed to in three weeks roll out
a new platform on top of gcp
that really allowed us to provide these
insights and information to our
government customers we signed up 26
customers or 27 now
since the pandemic started and have been
able to provide them with information
that can help them understand mobility
patterns what communities are
interconnected what health regions are
interconnected how far are people
traveling on an average day how well are
people receiving public health messaging
and doing all of this with large
aggregate data samples that nothing's
about individuals it's all about
communities and how communities are
interacting with each other and this has
resulted in some really positive effects
for various health groups across the
country which is something we're very
proud of and from doing this we actually
won the hpe iapp 2020 um innovation and
privacy award so it's a very big deal
for us and we're very excited to have
won that it really shows that privacy
differentiator is core to our product
and really core to what we do and it's
really helped us gain traction with
these government agencies
well first of all congratulations and
and then uh you know it's amazing thank
you for doing this for for the community
you're providing
a great service uh to everyone now you
have been a telus for nine years and
you've had a ton of uh experiences i
want to kind of step back and take a
look at overall why did you choose
google and what has been the the
improvement you've seen compared to
maybe on-prem systems and then we're
going to go into the do's and the domes
but first why google for you yeah so
before google we were trying to analyze
this data using an on-premise hadoop
cluster it was
what it was
it tried to be powerful enough we
continued to expand that cluster it was
getting very costly to do so we were
saying results to understand something
like maybe a tourism region's
visitorship was taking us about a month
to produce a month worth of information
so we were kind of running at that
bleeding edge where if we got one more
data point we went in our deadlines for
customers so we're getting in this very
concerned kind of mode of working where
it wasn't right and we knew there was
something better out there so we started
researching what different things were
out there we came across bigquery and
bigquery had a lot of benefits towards
gis data specifically so all of this
location data a lot of the analysis and
a lot of the complex analytics really
require standard geography libraries and
so what google has put into bigquery
there for standard geography was a
really strong differentiator for us and
then the general support we saw from the
google team so when we engaged google
they were very good about providing
specialists who would help us with
architecture it would help our teams
give us training really get us up to
speed and comfortable and finally the
fact that bigquery runs off of ansi
sequel meant that a lot of the stuff
we've built in the past could be
ripped out of the system was in and
placed up into the cloud quite quickly
and quite successfully and we saw that
when we first migrated about a year ago
a large chunk of our data and we were
able to move some of our algorithms
within days and get some very fast
results i think we had a 25 times speed
increase so what was taking a month was
taking
a day to run so it's a significant
difference in just that caliber result
and with that we're also able to really
really truly use our human capital as
well as possible so part of what we're
running is consulting and you ideally
want to reduce the number of man hours
taken because when i'm sitting to pay a
data scientist to watch a circle spin on
their screen while hadoop's chugging
away at a result i'm still paying for
their time whether or not that result's
coming through and so bigquery's also
allowed us to do more with a small team
and i we couldn't have done the things
we've done around covid without the
technology there
we hear this a lot from customers is
typically you know big data yields to
big questions but the ability to go
through the cycle faster you know
enables you to ask bigger questions but
also maybe better questions and maybe
more questions so it invites people to
innovate faster without having to worry
so much about the operational aspect of
it now you have learned a ton through
your experience and i want to know first
let's start with the positive side of
the equation as you're learning what it
means to
become data driven and be modernized in
the cloud what are some of the maybe two
three best practices you've learned in
this process
i think the number one best practice is
to keep on top of what's happening um
you guys are launching new tools and new
ways of looking at data new pieces
constantly and the rollout is quick
there's new stuff happening and keeping
on top of that can really save you a lot
of time we found that sometimes it's
faster to come to the google product
team and say hey we really want to be
able to do x and oftentimes you guys are
already working on that and can give us
a date when it's ready so it's faster
than us building it from scratch
ourselves and having to replace it a few
months later so really keeping on top of
kind of update logs being involved in
community forums understanding what's
happening with the product and how it's
evolving um that's a really big do and
has saved us a lot of headaches and a
lot of time getting close to the google
team kind of rolls into that but
understanding what the product team's
doing
being close to your sales agents
understanding what they're providing and
what they can help with the team's been
incredibly supportive it's been one of
the better experiences we've had i've
been in the software industry for about
10 years now and i would say it's second
to none in terms of the quality of
service we've received so really really
happy with that i think the closer you
can get with the people you're working
with from google the more you can gain
from that you guys are experts in your
platforms and your tools and you're
willing to share that expertise and
you're very good at sharing that
expertise in a very genuine way that
helps us move forward as a business
we've been really happy with that
and the third one something that i think
is true for any data science team
regardless of where you're working but
give people the opportunity to
experiment things don't always work the
same in bigquery as traditional database
technologies things don't always do what
you want them to do you really want to
give your people enough time to
experiment and play and do r d work if
you really want to see the true success
and drive those really big measures if
you don't give people time to kind of
explore they won't flourish as much as
they really can with these technologies
there's a bit of a paradigm shift in
terms of the thinking of how you have to
look at data in bigquery and how you
want to query it how you want to look at
it and giving people time to understand
that play with it and experiment can
really lead to some astonishing results
it can really improve how you're working
with it as much as things are ansi
sequel and you can rip and replace you
can do significantly better if you take
the time to look at how to optimize and
how to play around with it thank you for
for the feedback we're happy that you're
happy and it's true if you're in the
community we have roles dedicated to
your success from our you know customer
engineers through our
developer relations team and we have
people really focus on making sure
you're you're successful i'm assuming
you're also reading newsletters and and
other forms what's your favorite form
i'm curious
so chad from your gis group has a
community forum on google chat he set up
a really great forum there that has a
lot of the leading people in the
community and being able to see what
people are posting about see messaging
really get on top of that and the other
thing is the sales engineers we have a
lot of meetings with them to regularly
keep up to date on what products are
coming out what's new and exciting and i
find both of those are the best ways of
getting information for me because they
they're very knowledgeable on the
products more so than what i've seen
from most sales engineering groups they
really know what's coming up and what it
will do and they also taken the time to
understand our problems and know where
we're coming from so they know if a
product's a good fit for us and they're
often very on top of saying hey we have
this new thing launching you should
check it out and they know who to go to
within our team so they've been really
really good to work with
that's great to hear and yeah this
community you're talking about is the
what we call the dac the day analytics
customer council which is a a meeting
that we have we used to have this once a
year but now we have this every month so
it gives you more opportunities to
connect with our roadmap and our uh
developer organization engineering
organization and then of course there's
a group where you don't have to wait for
the meeting you can interact with the us
directly and the rest of the community
that's what it means to be part of the
data analytics community at google so
now that was for the positive let's talk
about some of the uh worst practices
some of them maybe the mistakes that
you've learned along the way
that you would tell someone getting
started today to try to avoid them yeah
the number one mistake is know what data
you have duplicated where how things are
set up in terms of retention policies
we made a stupid mistake of one of our
teams had accidentally set a default to
retain data for three years after
deletion so we thought we were deleting
data and we're watching our bills go up
and up and up and couldn't figure it out
we reached out we submitted support
tickets and someone from google realized
what was going on and corrected it for
us but it really taught us a big lesson
about cloud expenses can go way up i
mean relative to the human capital costs
again that we were seeing before on our
old infrastructure this is pales in
comparison like we really didn't pay
nearly as much for these mistakes as we
were paying to have people sit at a
computer so it was a good lesson to
learn but i would suggest people
are careful with things like retention
policies make sure you have the right
data in the right environments don't
over replicate your data if you don't
need to use things like views to allow
data to be accessed across environments
use the tools that are there to be
successful it's not traditional database
management you have to treat it a little
bit differently so that would be my
number one one because that has
some cost associated with it and it
rolls into my second one which is really
don't be afraid to fail at this like
things are going to go wrong you'll be
able to correct them you'll be able to
stand it back up again we launched a
major product in three weeks that was
meeting a very serious need in the
market for data around covid it's not
something we could have done on our old
infrastructure a lot of us spent some
very late nights in those three weeks
getting that up and running it was
probably closer to six to eight weeks of
actual work but still it's something
that can be done with this kind of tool
behind you and you can't do that on
traditional on-prem things just ordering
hardware alone would take you longer
than that so really the power is there
it just needs to be utilized and you
have to be not afraid to take that first
step and i think a lot of people are
afraid to take that first step because
they might get it wrong and it's not a
big deal because things are moving
faster you get something wrong you can
course correct much easier than you
could in traditional hardware type
database development so the other one is
don't expect this to magically fix
everything i think some of our team
especially at our executive level we're
expecting you know you go to the cloud
and suddenly there's no more problems
everything's better
brush your hands walk away kind of thing
and it's really not that this will fix
some of your problems it will introduce
some new problems you still need the
support teams you still need the
infrastructure people um their security
development still needs to be there
their roles might shift slightly in what
they're doing versus managing services
versus managing hardware but they're
still needed and they're still a
necessary part of those teams you're not
going to save costs on those kind of
things but where you will save costs are
on the actual people doing the work and
you'll be able to do more work with less
people which is really a bigger benefit
but don't expect just suddenly to be you
know one data scientist spinning up an
entire environment fixing everything and
solving all the problems where you're
gonna need teams to support these kind
of things and that's something that's
just necessary regardless of where you
go that's great you gave us a lot to
think about i mean there's a lot here
it's a very rich uh interview thanks for
giving us the time today you know two
things i think i want to highlight this
first
aspect of staying in touch
with the google team either through the
field resources you have for your
account or the many opportunities forms
and newsletters and groups that we have
created for you i really want to
encourage everyone to do that if you're
part of the community today and then the
second aspect you touched on on
financial governance you have to watch
out for how you set up your your system
of course but the good news here is
because you're in the cloud it's more
than just your team watching out which i
think is what you're talking about here
joe is that we managed to pick that up
and then tell you about it which is a
great way to make sure that everybody's
paying attention to how you're utilizing
and paying for resources
again thank you so much for the time
today i hope people are going to reach
out to you got a lot to share and we
appreciate you taking the time i'll talk
to you soon perfect thanks so much brito
take care
[Music]
you